new Indonesian sex laws basically in
Indonesia you're not allowed to have sex
outside of a committed relationship so
if there's two people that are just like
visiting going to Bali [ __ ] they
could potentially be like charged or
even jail because it's not just for
Citizens that's what's crazy why are you
hurting your own tourism like this
hey he's running from one place tonight
that's why they changed the law but
Russell kept doing it over there no this
is interesting it's like
so
I think what they're trying to do is
stop Bali from becoming like a uh a
vacation [ __ ] tourism place for you know
Western folks which is probably what's
becoming which is a bunch of beautiful
girls that are you know making money off
Instagram go live there because it's
probably so cheap to live and you can
live this amazing lifestyle it's one of
the most beautiful places in the world
and like culturally it's one of the most
uh rich and Rich I don't mean obviously
in terms of money I mean like in terms
of like acceptance love like everybody
Duval specifically he's like I've never
been to a place like that in my entire
life where the people just understand
life
and it's safe
how is there a place where things are
cheap and it's safe you understand about
Bali specifically yeah Bali specifically
interesting so so to me I understand the
government stepping in going hey we
don't want to be this place where like
westerners just come to like party in
the [ __ ] jungle suck each other's
dicks all the [ __ ] time like we have
this beautiful culture that there's just
desecrated
yeah yeah I think it kind of went like
that we have this beautiful island
there's a second each other
I was in the jungle and I and I thought
it was a bunch of baboons going out it
turns out it was these Australians
[ __ ] each other's dicks in the jungle
dude you know a little baby feels the
babies on stage stop sucking each
other's dicks all the time in the jungle
Mark the mighty jungle the mighty jungle
yeah so
basically
I I get what they're doing and
listen I haven't been I don't know how
bad it's getting but I can't understand
if the culture that you saw that was so
prevalent there
this like Wax Western sex tourism not in
terms of like paying prostitutes but in
terms of just like you know singles
hooking up if that doesn't coincide with
the culture that you guys have lived
within for thousands of years you can
make a change you're not upset if
married couples go there and they hook
up you're not upset if maybe even
boyfriend girlfriend it's like pseudo
marriage or something like that what you
don't want is the swinger [ __ ]
lifestyle people going to bars and just
meeting and sucking each other but I
heard to get in trouble it's only uh the
parent has to report the child
I think that's the only way you can get
in trouble for it but what if the
parent's not there that's what I'm
saying so I don't that's why they made
the law that way so it won't deter
tourism interesting so is it just a law
that is trying to stop specific types of
people from going
but it's not really enforceable not
worth it to stop the women of Bali from
being that's what it is being part of
like a sex trade yeah or uh or
westerners whatever just kind of using
them for sex I think that's the biggest
thing what they're trying to stop yeah I
get that 100 yo you guys can come [ __ ]
here you guys could do your devil
Behavior here okay if you want you guys
can go into the jungle and have at it
with each other's dicks in your mouth
yeah but you cannot suck our dicks okay
our dicks are yeah of course they're
trying to steal our dicks dude they
really they were going after they're
going over here and they're stealing
their [ __ ] dicks dude they're
stealing their [ __ ] dicks crazy dude
they're a balinesian ball sacks getting
sucked in a jungle shake my head bro
dude there's rainy season out there
and there are two Polynesian guys this
should be building like a house out of
mud for YouTube videos but instead
but instead someone's [ __ ] their dick
maybe that's how they pulled all those
houses bro maybe that's what they use to
stick them together yeah and maybe
they're sick and tired of it maybe
they've built too many of these houses
maybe there's a housing crisis there's
so many houses there's too many [ __ ]
Huts what are we gonna do with all these
Huts I don't know we don't have enough
people living in them because guys
they're sucking each other's dicks yeah
instead of stuffing them in them little
Balinese boxes and making some babies
yeah they can live in them [ __ ] Huts
yes
right right now